the thing that's surprising is
how
bold he is at being and and transparent
with it because generally let's be
honest the base has been resistant to
opening the borders so to speak on the
exclusive titles and things like like
that king is laughing at least
so my question is do you think like what
avenue do you think it takes do you
think it takes like okay are we doing um
you know moving that now more
aggressively to pc or is this mobile
like what avenue does this take because
he clearly the 10 million for the
playstation exclusive is not not
satiating him he's not satisfying him
right so
when he really where do you think he
takes it as far as this i think he takes
it where his board members tell him to
go okay
all right his board members are telling
him hey listen you put out a couple of
playstation 5 exclusives yo you can't
get the console to everyone and we took
a bath on x y and z
and that's just not cutting it there's a
reason
there's a there's a
there's a reason why all of these og
playstation games uh you know ips like
god of war and horizon and and and and
the rest of them are going to eventually
be on playstation 4 because you have to
make the money i listen this is this is
not surprising but again it does put jim
in a bad light because this is not what
he was talking about only about a month
a month or two ago and now he's going
back look the reality is this
playstation fans here comes the band-aid
ripping rip it's day and dates to
wherever it's gonna go and you're just
gonna have to you're just gonna have to
suck it because that's business
okay so his new name once that happens
it's gonna be worldwide gym
the streets and the streets is for
everybody
let's go
i do want to say this um shout out shout
out to phil spencer because when they
first initiated everything in terms of
putting xbox games on pc will start
there right when they first initiated
that it caught a little heat right yeah
but the best thing they could have done
for me was putting this game on pc
because i got another way to play it yes
jim ain't playing with y'all so now we
look at game plays okay so look now we
look at game pads right now the 30 31
million number
i'm not going to say that it's true or
false but phil spencer could have
corrected him what he said what phyllis
pence said in the interview was he said
the last time we reported it was 18
minutes right right so you're not wrong
but we just yeah that was very pr very
pr so so first of all uh ceo will take
two slow down a little bit don't put our
business out there
oh that was the translation
slow down my guy you do it too much
the first public reported novel was 18
continue
but he was happy because they booed up
going on over there i'm sure um the
third thing i want to say is um in the
words of damon wayne's uh mo money mo
money mo listen if y'all crazy if y'all
we saw all this stuff coming to pc the
second we saw what was that horizon zero
dawn and people made a big big shout out
to my homie jack move johnny he made a
whole thing about it
i said oh nice over it's it's a wrap now
maybe we might we may not get these
games day one but according to this
report my man said hundreds of millions
and he really meant he really meant
billions for real because if we are
going to take that xbox model that phil
expensive motto look we're putting it on
the phone though yeah this is right
there
um got to cut you um hustle i did have a
topic not too long ago that i was
bringing to the realm you remember that
topic cog when i was talking about
playstation games going to the cell
phone yes yes
continue sorry i do apologize but i did
have that topic we showed that topic
yeah because the topic was dated right
but it's it
ain't nobody look nobody can they write
mine and jimmy he is a jimmy i'mma call
him
jimmy jimmy is a businessman he do care
about the numbers man and look
shout out to all the playstation fan
boys on twitter on youtube you're not
good enough
yo you are not good enough it don't
matter oh yeah we sold you know how many
councils we sold right we might say we
hit 80 million right we playstation's
over 80 million costumes only 10 million
of y'all bought it that's not good
enough
we need more of this no no we need more
of this oh wait y'all want to play on yo
on the phone
you can play on the tv we can play we
can play it on the phone you can play it
on your tablet all right look we wait
how how much money how much money still
in the making kid all right cool we on
that too yo he saw a field
money wait a caller they only sold seven
million we sold ten how come i didn't
get a yacht
how come i can get it
that's that that's that billion dollar
talk that's how i go there man
that's when jim said okay no that's
enough for this
enough for this
i'm the truth out of here
it's now we i've seen this coming for a
long time maybe not the phone thing so
much so like when i saw when i saw that
interview when you sent it to me cognito
i was like oh
oh if it wasn't over before if you
didn't think you lost your girl before
she gone she's she she is for everybody
it is over it doesn't mean that the
quality right of something like this
will change no question it doesn't mean
that the quality is going to change per
se it means a whole lot more money
coming in it means a lot more
opportunities i actually am looking
forward to this for like the indie
people who are around who are you know
are in game pass right who are in
playstation now like they get the
they they get the best benefit out of
that we you know ergonomics never yells
probably one of my you know favorite
games this year it's only about an hour
and a half but i got to take the time to
like do that because this gentleman made
this game by itself
if it's on phones and it's on
playstation and it's on xbox and it's on
it if it's everywhere and everybody see
it you're not you get to it so as a
indie developer all day but nah jimmy
jimmy want that bread though he want
that money
much more to be said i mean king would
probably just laugh at what he saw this
dude this is what he's been saying for
so long boom said things so eloquently
yeah i mean
it just comes to show you there's a
difference between you know
the fanboyism and the boardroom right
and the fanboyism and the pride and we
get it you know we we're never going to
disrespect and say playstation hasn't
been successful we're never going to say
that you know these games are hidden and
they quality exclusives but the reality
is it's like you know hustle said like
in his mind that's not enough you know
like king said like he said yo that's
not enough and the only way i could
visualize them
improving and increasing this scope is
bringing these games to pc bringing
these games to mobile you know doing
what you got to do cloud streaming
services that stuff on xbox
i don't know if it's going there but if
i get a hold of god of war on my xbox
you guys better run
yeah you will be popping bottles i know
yeah
it's it's i think for me the interesting
thing charting jim ryan
is each time they speak to him the
bolder he gets
yeah because let's be honest you know
the playstation communities are very
mean
it's about to go omega
they're very passionate you know
community and you know they take things
very seriously so even
remember put it this way hustler man we
will get twitter seriously
if they took it seriously
listen remember like we would watch the
shows and demon souls were in and it'd
be this curious mistake coming to pc at
the bottom oh no no that was that was a
mistake you know and i'm like there's no
way there's a mistake like that's
already done you just wasn't ready so
what it is it is like a grooming it is
like a we gotta get them on board slowly
because we know a lot of we're
light-petting
a lot of people are resisted but this is
the direction they're going to me it's
clear as day it's clear that and the way
i look at it is like yo if it's if it's
going to help playstation get more money
to allow them to have more sequels and
you know bring the games that we want to
get out of the console business they
putting out these high-priced weak
consoles let's just get past this and
let's get these to everyone
look at the end of the day i get you i
get it but it's like at the end of the
day
he did say a good point it's gated the
the way shout out to sean layton he even
said it recently shout out to barry in
person
he said it like there's only a certain
amount of money in that box even if
you're the best you get all there's a
box on that console speed there's a
ceiling right
after a while it's like yo with the
horizon cost the games the way things is
and development you can't afford these
things to flop and not get that back and
you trying to hit more so even if it
means yo let the pc community eat you
know let them get a taste of what's
going on here king is stupid
cause you really clearly
no i'm just with you
i'm paying the moment everything
like i said just even if they get on pc
people want to eat and more people want
to get a hold of these games and you're
seeing it with the tvs as well and it's
implementation things like that so
this is where it's going y'all this is
where it's going the key for me the
curious thing for me and my last point
we'll move on is i want to see if they
do anything with the playstation now
or the ps plus model if anything they
change because we know the last thing
that a lot of people are holding on to
obviously is day to day i'm not there
yet they did it crunchyroll